i think there's like 100 rips in this by
now i am loving the punk princess vibes
though thank you how really difficult to
get on and to get in the car and all
that stuff i was going to say how was
the car ride over here in this it was
honestly like i felt so fierce though so
it was like worth it hunk princess girl
congratulations on this film you kicked
some major booty what did training look
like ahead of these fight scenes
training was pretty um pretty intense i
trained for quite a bit and i trained
very hard every day training was um i'd
never done something like this before so
i was very nervous it was very scary for
me to jump into something head first
that i'd never done before but i did
know for a fact that i wanted to get to
a point in my training process where i
was able to do
most of my own fighting most of my own
stunts and everyone on the stunt team in
this movie every single person that
trained me my stunt devils who helped
train me every day they supported me so
much and they lifted me up so much to
the point where
like 85 to 90 of what you see on screen
is actually me and i think i couldn't
have done that without everyone that
lifted me up how grueling was that on
your body because i hear it was like
eight to ten hour long days you had a
cast on your arm how grueling was that
on your body it was crazy i mean we had
definitely longer than eight to ten but
we were fighting we were fighting all
the way for eight to ten um it was like
i mean
listen my i have bad hips in general too
so i would be like sitting there like
just there gunning my legs at night like
crying but i did have a cast at the
beginning i had wrist surgery and that
was on my right hand and i wound up
sword fighting with my right hand
i like a girl in lace
there was a lot of blood sweat tears a
lot of perseverance
um but honestly like the pain and the
stuff that my body went through
throughout all this
everything like it was kind of addicting
how much fun i had on it so i wouldn't
change anything you crushed it girl
thank you so much and now you're taking
those fighting skills to bullet train
with brad pitt what did you learn from
brad about stunt work
i mean brad is just like so agile and
impressive and gorgeous so i mean
there's a lot to learn from someone who
can pull off all of those at the same
time and then next we have a film with
zac efron too i mean you're late 90s
baby were you a huge zack man growing up
absolutely oh my god are you kidding of
course i was and he is i mean i can't
wait to work with him he's just
fantastic uh and yeah i'm obviously a
huge fan of this
between all these films girl when are
you wedding planning
right i don't know um i'm just honestly
like getting into the thick of wedding
planning but also i'm just like so
enjoying being engaged because we always
say me and stephen we're always like you
know we're you're engaged only once for
a very short period of time in your life
once you're married you're married
forever but like you know we're so
excited to be engaged we're really just
sitting in every day of it and just
having it's like so much fun he like
threw me a curveball one day by saying
like he like straight up out of the blue
was like do you want to be part of ring
shopping and i was like what
so he actually did all of it himself and
he
he is he has amazing taste in everything
in life and so
the fact that he found this gorgeous
designer and gorgeous ring i mean it
doesn't surprise me but i'm just so in
love with it it's amazing i'm so happy
for you is this a little tease for the
wedding dress are you gonna go a little
smaller can you imagine oh my god no i
hope not i mean i do like the idea of
dramatics but this is just like i'm
schvitzing under i'm like chafing you
want to be able to dance yeah i can't
dance i mean like i can like two-step a
little bit i'm changing immediately
after we stop this interview
[Music]